Film Courage: The last time we interviewed you in 2015, you
were in Ventura [California]? Markus Redmond, Writer/Director/Actor/Producer: Right. Film Courage: Beautiful Ventura.
And now you've returned to the LA
area. I know a lot of things have
changed here in terms of traffic and
gentrification and all of that. Aside from those
very real things, have you noticed that
the way the industry works has changed?
Markus: Totally. It's completely different in so
many ways. Like so
alright 2015 so that's four years four
and a half maybe like everything's like
the onset of streaming is probably the
the largest difference the onset of
YouTube influencers becoming
millionaires on YouTube huge difference
the changes we've had in politics the
changes that we've had in culture yeah
it's way different now there are
sections of people that just can't get
stuff done no more you know because
they're not the right fit for the way
the world is so yeah there's been a lot
of differences a lot of changes when
you've tried to get in front of someone
to pitch or whatever it is get a project
together
do you notice changes in that in terms
of how it used to be I don't know how
long you'd been gone yeah I mean I am
now in that sort of midway point where
I'm interested in doing independent
things but it's sort of evolved itself
into a higher level so there's more
money involved and because there's more
money involved there's more necessities
Oh like what um when you're asking folks
for
more money they want some sort of
assurance that they're going to get some
return on their investment more often
than not a great script is not that to
them no matter how great they believe it
is it's about eyeballs how can I get a
ton of eyeballs on this thing so that I
can turn a profit get my money back or
get my money back and turn a profit
there's a lot of stuff going on right
now so they need name attachments
director attachments something you know
that's why they keep making superhero
movies that's why I carry PI psycho and
I know people love them and and they
should because there's a huge worldwide
market for that but they keep making
them because there's a huge worldwide
market for that you know so it's like
hey I want to make a movie about flowers
in the Sun I want to make a movie about
Ironman bring what Ironman because
there's a lot more there and you know
some people love it some people hate it
but you got to respect it that's what
that's that's what that is you can't
really can't get around that so you've
got to be able to understand the
business that you're in
it's one thing to stick to your guns
creatively and I'm totally down for that
I completely respect that because I
think you have to be that way especially
in this business cuz it can get very
dogged but you also have to respect the
industry in the way it works
a lot of people say it's not it's not
place it's just your work that gets it
notice so having moved like two hours
now back yeah do you feel that it's
easier to get stuff done now that you're
here in LA or get stuff seen rather than
being just a short drive away it's
beautiful train ride away yeah in a town
that is gorgeous and you can find a nice
place to have lunch know how you know
there's like an urgency to areas too
I've heard the same about San Diego even
though it's again two hours from LA the
urgency maybe isn't the same as when
you're in LA even faster did you know I
mean yeah of course it's a it's a big
city you know Ventura is not but that's
not the reason I mean the reason is who
you're working with and and how much
work you're putting in you know I mean
if I was working with like a really
great production company right and I was
still in Ventura at the pot it wouldn't
I don't think there would have been any
sort of time difference or difference in
getting stuff done it's just you know
just more driving back and forth to
meetings and stuff I don't think it's I
mean yeah if you live in you know
Nebraska it's better to be in LA because
there's more stuff happening in LA then
in Omaha but you know if you're just
talking about you know an hour or two
drive difference hmm that's not any
different it's just a matter of like how
much work you're putting in and maybe
it's easier to be lazy if you're not in
town perhaps it's easier if you're in
Ventura like San Diego or wherever
perhaps it's easier to not put in the
work because maybe it's perceived as
being harder but it's not do you think
there's an energy here in LA that pushes
you to keep working whereas maybe
Ventura it's too comfortable it's too
like yeah I can find a parking spot at
the beach no prob I know
yeah and here mean you will drive around
the block okay do I really want to pay
twenty dollars to park in the spot right
well I mean you know I'm gonna have to
park at the very end right do you know
for sure I mean listen if you live in a
basketball town and you like croquette
it's gonna be very hard for you but if
you move to a town where they love
croquette you're probably gonna play a
lot more croquette you know what I mean
so yeah you're you're in the city where
it's happening there's definitely a
bigger larger energy that's happening in
Los Angeles everybody's not everybody
but a lot of folks are connected to the
entertainment industry and people are
moving and shaking there's a lot of
ideas floating around you probably can
connect to people that are part of your
tribe easier because they have already
made the commitment and they're here and
they're doing stuff I always admire
people I meet people to come here and
they're working and they're from like
Sweden you know what I mean and it's
like so you lived like in Sweden can you
spoke Swedish but you wanted to make
movies so you left everything you knew
and you learned a different language you
got on a plane without ain't guarantee
of anything and you took a one-way
ticket trip to Los Angeles and figured
out how to like get an apartment and get
a job so you could pursue this thing
like that's I do my head is off to
anybody who makes that trip that is a he
I just had to drive down from Ventura
it's nothing there are people come in
here from countries you know what I mean
I've ever even their families behind
there like you know suffering through
holidays alone lonely because they
believe in something like just no way
can not respect that type of person do
you think it makes you more competitive
being here probably are you competitive
no yeah can you still be successful and
not be competitive I hope so
I I don't know I mean no I mean I think
you got to do what you do and then find
folks to dig what you do you know you
can get mad about something or somebody
it's doing something similar to you and
that's fine but then that's a lot of
energy of yours that could be spent
creating something else of yours spent
on hating this person and you know you
know they don't give you time back which
is my understanding I don't know I don't
know if you get to the end and then they
go wow you save some time so here here's
another year and a half I don't know
that that happens so you know I think I
think it's better to just be mindful of
your own your own track which again is
why I'm always saying more than one
thing always always always always
especially like if you really dig
something like if you've got a lot of
stuff and you really want to do
something a certain way if you've got
more content you've got the option to
say that you know like I've got I have a
catalogue of projects and I have it
split like this is the stuff I want to
do my way and this is the stuff we're
selling and that we really like this but
we want to add a raccoon to it do it do
it that raccoon could end up making 200
million dollars at the box office and
then I can pull this thing out and I can
say okay remember that movie I made with
you at the raccoon we made all that
money I want you to make this movie now
and they'll go alright
you gave us the Rico so you know I think
it's important to have that it's not
easy necessarily I mean you know
everybody's wired differently but I
think the more stuff you
stockpile the better
you